deep in the Siberian forest is the
record of an explosion that is a
thousand times larger than Hiroshima it
was a summer morning in the Pingu schoo
River Basin a man was sitting on his
porch enjoying the the sunlight on his
face when suddenly he was a blown
backwards out of his chair and he felt
as if his whole body was on fire he was
forty miles away from the center of this
explosion window shattered for hundreds
of miles around
shockwaves rippled across Europe the
night sky was illuminated for weeks
after and people were able to read their
newspapers in the middle of the night
from London to Asia it was 20 years
before a scientist was actually able to
make it out to the site of this disaster
Leonid Kulik the chief curator of
meteorite collection at the st.
Petersburg Museum made a journey out in
1927 it was an arduous trip it took
forever to get to this remote area in
the Siberian wilderness and what he
found shocked him he found 83 million
trees felled in a circular radius
covering over 600 miles at the center of
this the trees stood straight up burned
to a crisp and stripped of their bark
and their branches locals were at first
really reluctant to talk to him they
thought that this explosion had been the
work of octi a God who had come down to
punish them by destroying their land and
their livestock
so hundred years later there are still
questions about exactly what happened at
the Tunguska event a space object may be
a comment but probably a meteorite
entered the Earth's atmosphere this
thing was 200 feet wide and probably
weighed over 220 million pounds and it
came into the atmosphere at around
33,000 miles per hour
as it sped towards the Earth's surface
it encountered the push back the
friction of the atmosphere which heated
to over 45,000 degrees and it was at
this moment that it exploded it sent out
a shock wave in a butterfly pattern
imagine an explosion so powerful that it
could explode miles above the Earth's
surface and still measure as a 5.0 on
the Richter scale had it happened over a
city it easily could have leveled an
area the size of Tokyo and here's the
thing well it was relatively rare
astronomers have done the math and they
think an event like this happens roughly
every 300 years
so depending on probability we've got
another Tunguska event in our near
future subscribe here and watch more
videos here there should be little
explosions happening little explosions
didn't happen that something went wrong
the debate still goes on about whether
it was a meteorite or a comet there are
good arguments for both some Italian
scientists believe that they have in
fact found the impact crater
checo Lake of course the locals are like
you know that Lakes definitely been here
forever
so it's it's a little it's a little bit
hard to say it there is a weird theory
that it is a kind of a gas vent that was
releasing an enormous amount of our
methane I guess we're created kind of a
huge pool of gas in the sky going down
to the vent and then it was struck by
lightning and it was like a wick down to
this gas crater and it exploded in his
enormous insane way but it's a lot more
likely that it was just a meteor